all right so if the HTC One m9 and the
Samsung Galaxy Note 4 had a baby yeah
this is what we'd get this is the HTC
One m9 plus so okay wait a second we
have the HTC One m9 that we see in
stores everyone knows that but what is
this Plus version in short it's just a
slightly better version of the flagship
that's already out as the name implies
so okay check this out here's a couple
of new additions number one a slightly
larger 5.2 inch quad HD display yes 2560
by 1440
so it's 0.2 inches larger and also
brighter and sharper than the 1080p
display in the regular one m9 it's also
a little bit slightly cooler and color
temperature but overall the superior
display and then at the bottom as I'm
sure you've already noticed on the front
here is a fingerprint sensor so just
like the Samsung or Apple flagships you
can now register a couple of finger
prints to unlock the phone just by
touching your finger to the sensor so no
swiping necessary it's actually really
good - for me it's been just as fast and
accurate as the one in the Apple or
Samsung flagship phone so it's actually
not a home button it doesn't press in at
all it's just a surface that looks like
the Samsung home button but you can't
actually wake the device by tapping it
you'll have to either double tap the
display or use the actual power button
on the side of the phone to get in and
the actual software home button to go
home but once you do get in it's the
exact same software experience as a
regular one m9 with just a few
differences thanks to it actually being
for the Chinese market which I'll get to
in a second inside it's pretty powerful
too it's rocking a 64-bit octa-core 2.2
gigahertz chip and three gigabytes of
RAM again it's not the Snapdragon 810 or
anything but it is packin a lot of power
here and curiously enough even though it
is a little bit of a bigger phone it
does still have the same sized battery
so it's still rocking a 2840 milliamp
hour battery like the regular one m9 but
the last big difference here is around
the back and it's the camera or cameras
it's rocking a 20 megapixel sensor again
this time with the round housing instead
of square and you have your dual LED
flash and then up top you have your
depth sensor again that one
from the One m8 of last year so the m9
doesn't even have this at all now you
can take your photos with all the glory
of 20 megapixels and also still have the
choice between some of HTC's corny duo
camera effects not saying they'll be
pretty photos but hey the effects are
there so either way it is a slightly
larger phone it's a slightly different
phone it's pretty comparable to hold on
the hand still has the same button
placement as the original One m9 but
everything else is straight from that
already popular flagship so from the
excellent build quality to the pretty
much unmatched boom sound speakers so
this brings to mind what we saw with the
prime phones of last year we had this
self named LG g3 prime and the Samsung
Galaxy s5 prime and I did a video about
both of those sort of explaining what
Prime phones are and the same applies
here this HTC One m9 plus is another one
of those phones that's only going to be
sold in China and if you want to get any
in your pocket you'll have to import it
which comes at a cost of its own
shout-out to D brand skins for helping
out with that and yet it has its own
optimizations for that market because as
far as HTC is concerned this is what the
Chinese market wants and the one m9 we
see here in US stores is exactly what
the US market wants now I'm not saying I
disagree with that but I'll tell you
right now I would have loved to see the
one m9 plus in stores here considering
that it's basically objectively a better
phone than the one m9 in a couple of
ways also there have been rumblings of a
samsung galaxy s6 plus and as far as I
know this photo which was given to me by
an anonymous source is the first one on
the Internet of that so there's your
exclusive and it'll have some pretty
similar excellent specs and be a sort of
a super-sized version of the original
Galaxy s6 so there you go plus is the
new prime thanks for watching guys and
I'll talk to you in the next one peace
you